a sweet tooth do you want to go get some
ice cream over there that would be let's
do it okay
[Music]
how are you oh you got some good ice
cream what do you have here a dove bar
that's a good old safe apartment special
I'll have a dump bar too
[Music]
so I know you like Forrest Gump a little
bit does this remind you you've lived a
life a little bit like Forrest Gump I've
had some Forrest Gump it's got every
time I'm around here I was thinking
sorry people why would we start your
Monday morning with state-run propaganda
from the televised mental institution
known as MSNBC with chronic liar Jen
Saki and evil globalist John Kerry I
don't know why we would do that who's in
charge around here it really makes you
wonder I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it's April 24th 2023 we're live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and locals I
just have to say one thing I just busted
this shirt out it's a new shirt
something's a little crazy with the
collar but we were in a Mad Dash today
the the boys are both a little little
under the weather so I was doing I was
doing Daddy Duty and I did not have time
to change my shirt so bear I look like a
like a mafia guy that just like did a
hit and now I'm going to the restaurant
after and they're gonna be like why is
this color rule you know you got it we
got a post game show for you
rubyreport.locals.com immediately after
the show and it is a Haywire week around
here we're going to be doing a bunch of
pre-tapes because in in a couple days I
leave for a long trip going to be gone
for about was it 14 15 days going to
Israel and Hungary we're going to be
doing a bunch of Live Events and I'm
doing some speaking gigs and we're going
to go to the holy sites and the
governmental buildings and all of the
stuff that one can do when one is out
across the globe and we're going to be
putting up tons of content we're
pre-taping a bunch of stuff and
interviews and all that so bear with us
but I am very excited for this trip and
and it sounds like a lot of good things
are going to come of it so stay tuned on
all that and the theme today
is about lying and the lying Liars who
tell the lies because they are basically
everywhere at this point whether it is
AOC who lies about everything whether it
is cringe Jean-Pierre who lies about
everything or unfortunately uh whether
it's Donald Trump who seems to have
veered into a place where now he wants
to lie about everything and regardless
of whether you're a Democrat a
republican a liberal or a conservative
if we all just decide that lying is how
we're going to do this thing then we
will all what are we going to do you
know we are all going to go on that slow
descent to Hell together and it seems
like a whole bunch of people really want
to take us there so I'm going to try to
punch some holes in some of the lies
today because there's been an awful lot
of them and I'm going to try to do it in
a bipartisan manner because they're
coming from the left and the right and
then of course as you know because I
don't just like focusing on the negative
we're going to focus a bit on how you
come combat the lies and you know
with the truth if you walk straight
through sure it's hot people are
throwing things at you saying mean
things to you on Twitter but I think on
the other side uh it can get a bit
better this caller Jesus uh before we do
any of that let me talk to you guys
about Birch gold you know inflation has
its consequences as the FED raises
interest rates to combat out of control
government spending long-term bonds have
diminished in value crippling banks
depositors are holding their breath and
investors are bailing on Bank stocks
diversification has never been more
important the recent surge in gold
prices is directly tied to extreme
Market volatility right now which is why
gold has been historically fantastic as
a hedge against the stock market and
against inflation now would be a great
time to diversify into gold with Birch
gold group Birch gold makes it easy to
convert an IRA or 401K into an IRA and
precious metals here's what you got to
do visit birchgold.com Dave to get a
free info kit on gold they'll help you
convert your IRA a or 401K that's tied
to a volatile Market into an IRA in
physical precious metals gold and silver
and the best part it's tax shelter visit
birchgold.com Dave to claim your free
info kit on gold today with an A plus uh
rating with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of happy customers and
countless five-star reviews Birch gold
is who you can trust to protect your
future that's birchgold.com Dave and now
back to me okay let's get into the lying
liars and the lies that they tell here
is LARPing New York congresswoman AOC
and she doesn't like it that people are
allowed to say things that she doesn't
like and she wants to step on the First
Amendment to stop them from saying such
things
and I believe that we leave to the
courts to solve issues that politics is
really supposed to solve that our
legislating is supposed to solve we have
very real issues with
um what is permissible on air and we saw
that with January 6th and we saw that in
the lead up to January 6th and how we
navigate questions not just of freedom
of speech but also accountability for
incitement of violence these are this is
the line that we have to really explore
through law as well and do you think
media organizations or social media
platforms should be accountable for the
role for being platforms for incitement
I believe that when it comes to
broadcast television like Fox News these
are subject to
to federal law Federal Regulation in
terms of what's allowed on air and what
isn't and when you look at what Tucker
Carlson and some of these other folks on
Fox do it is very very clearly
incitement of violence very clearly
incitement of violence and that is the
line that I think we have to be willing
to contend with okay so I want to speak
very clearly because that's what AOC
does I so I want to speak very very
clearly AOC should be impeached I know
no one will have the balls to do it but
AOC as a sitting congresswoman is
attacking the Constitution the very
thing she swore to protect right when
they take that oath of office we played
it for you last week even her communist
AOC did take the oath of office she kept
looking down while she was doing it
because it was killing her soul to have
to say that she was going to protect the
Constitution but remember this is the
second time I'm in two weeks she has had
a direct assault on our constitution
last week she was telling the bid
Administration that they should ignore
the Court ruling when it came to this
abortion pill now it simply does not
matter what your opinion on abortion is
or whether they should ever be legal or
when they should be legal or woman's
right to privacy or any of those things
that's a separate issue altogether and
we can debate that until we're blue in
the face but a sitting member of
Congress telling so she's in the
legislative branch telling the head of
the Executive Branch the president that
he should ignore something from the
judicial branch that's the Supreme Court
that strikes me as as a blatant and
gross violation of her oath of office
her oath of office is to protect the
Constitution not to shred it and then in
this case what is she doing she is going
directly after the first amendment she
does not want Fox News hosts or
certainly people who watch Fox News or
any of you or me to be able to exercise
their right to free speech specifically
she's going after Tucker and saying that
Tucker has very clearly very clearly
incited violence now we spent some time
this morning as we often do looking for
those videos where Tucker said go attack
the capitol burn down buildings attack
police officers etc etc now ironically
well of course we couldn't find it but
ironically during the summer I love
remember when the leftists and BLM and
antifa were burning down
buildings and Pep Boys and targets and
Mayhem on the streets AOC and Maxine
Waters and the rest of the Democrats
Lori Lightfoot Etc were basically for it
and saying get up in people's faces and
you know if you destroy property that's
not actually violence and the rest of it
words or violence burning down a Pep
Boys not violence so she has had two
within two weeks two absolute direct
assaults in violation of her oath of
office so we can either start being
serious people to get out of this
endless descent to hell and someone can
say something to her like you got to
roll this stuff back or you're going to
get impeached or we will just continue
now obviously the Democrats are
basically all for this and I don't think
the Republicans have the balls to do it
I will gladly talk to uh Kevin McCarthy
next time I see him and ask him about
that now obviously the Republicans alone
wouldn't have enough votes I think it
would be two-thirds of Congress if I'm
not mistaken but just the exercise of
doing it we will not sit back while you
you attack the founding documents that
you were sworn to protect but okay let's
continue on the liar train cringe
Jean-Pierre who took over for Jan saki
she is now the White House Press
Secretary this woman should be studied
by scientists she can't say anything
truth you thought saki couldn't say
anything true every now and again saki
would leak a little truth accidentally
remember saki oh we uh we do flag posts
for Facebook she didn't really mean to
say it but she kind of leaked it out
this one Karin jump here she is so in
over her head she was obviously a
diversity hire she's a black lesbian I
don't care about her skin color or her
sexuality but that's why they hired her
it's as simple as that here she is 100
percent lying about Florida's
don't say good
I also want to say a word about the
decision yesterday made by the Florida
Board of Education to expand the state's
dystopian don't say gay law
as this measure takes effect it will
prohibit all students up to seniors in
high school from learning about our
learning about or discussing lgbtqi plus
people in the classrooms teachers in
Florida have already faced a devastating
consequences of the existing law under
threat of having their licenses revoked
gay teachers have been forced to take
down pictures of their spouses from
their desks and censor their classroom
materials
centering our classes is not how public
education is supposed to work in a free
country
conservative politicians love to
complain about the so-called cancel
culture all while threatening teachers
with losing their jobs if they teach
something that the Maga extremists don't
agree with
get help you lying sack of ugh these
people it's only Monday uh okay let's
just go through it there is no assault
on lgbtqi people here in Florida please
show me what teachers have been fired
for doing any of these things it is
simply not true this idea that a teacher
can't have a picture of their spouse or
boyfriend or girlfriend on their desk
completely not true actually Community
notes which is Twitter's new crowd
sourced uh fact-checking system they
completely blew her apart on this it's
completely not true there's obviously
nothing in the bill for that you cannot
talk about sex and gender and sexuality
outside of the disciplines say health
class where it should be taught you're
it's not that a social studies class
can't when it's teaching about Civics
talk about the Supreme Court ruling on
gay marriage it's an absolute abject lie
uh and also this idea that that classes
and teachers and and schools can't
censor at all now I'm not for censorship
but there are some things we shouldn't
be teaching should we be teaching Nazism
in schools now ironically what the woke
want to teach is far closer to Nazism
it's race essential race essentialism uh
they so they sort of do want to teach
their own version of Nazism but
obviously you can teach about the Nazis
without teaching about Nazism as the the
philosophic uh point lies lies all they
do is lie and you know what guys lies
are bad wiser bad and there's a guy I
know who talks about that an awful lot
so if you say things that you know not
to be true or you don't say things that
you know to be true when you need to
which is more common
and if you act in ways that you consider
that act in ways you consider
reprehensible then you pathologize all
of those autonomous systems that guide
you it's like you're programming them
badly you're building an AI system
inside yourself really in in some sense
that is what you're doing that has very
bad it's very bad training data and so
the output it produces will be will
won't guide you properly and so you
don't want to pathologize your guidance
systems it's a really bad idea so that's
why you have to not lie and maybe that's
also why you have to say what you have
to say and you have to say it clearly as
well and you have to learn how to do
that
yeah you do you don't want to
pathologize your guidance system but
that's what these people have done
they've lied about so many things for so
long Donald Trump verified people on
both sides Russia hoax Jesse Smollett
Covington kids Brett Kavanaugh's cereal
rapist like all of the stuff America's
systemically racist we could do this all
day long they lie about everything and
what Jordan talks about it's not just
the active lies if you censor yourself
if you do not say what you know to be
true first of you acquiesce to them you
give them more air you give them more
fuel to keep moving on you but you also
have a corrosive effect on yourself
right one of the things Jordan would
often talk about when we were on tour
together people would ask him this this
question came up constantly I get this
at College events a lot now too is kids
would say you know I'm a freshman or
sophomore in college and you know I'm
not a leftist but my teacher if I write
a paper and I don't say exactly what the
teacher wants I'm not going to get the
good grade and then I'm not going to get
into grad school and if I don't get into
grad school I'm not going to get the job
I want if I don't get the job I want I'm
not going to get the house I want
and Jordan would always say you know if
you as a freshman are willing to lie or
not say what you think on a paper or in
a class or when you raise your hand and
the Teacher Calls on you or whatever it
is it'll be kind of easy to do the first
couple times you do it right it'll be
just you'll just do it and then as time
goes by you will completely forget that
person the person who was conflicted
about it at first right you will just
have given up and if you think it's hard
to fight the power when you're a
freshman in college because you want
that grade because you want grad school
and everything else just imagine do you
think you're going to get out into the
real world and suddenly start telling
the truth oh now I've got a car payment
and mortgages and a spouse and kids and
a dog and a whole bunch of other stuff
you think you're going to suddenly start
telling the truth it ain't how it is we
have to stop playing this game and look
guys I'm not going to sit here and tell
you that I've never lied obviously I
have obviously I really try not to I
really try not to and there's a
difference between outright outrageous
lies White Lies to protect somebody's
feelings or whatever it might be but you
get the point you get the point and now
I'm going to connect that to much uh a
much bigger thing that's happening I
think sort of in the country right now
but before I do let me talk to you guys
about Patriot Supply real quick uh guys
are you concerned about having enough
food in case of a sudden emergency
grocery stores can get strip bare within
hours if you don't have backup food on
your hand you might be finding yourself
relying on the government you don't want
that my Patriot Supply is making a
special offer to help everyone and
prepare now for what could be coming act
now and you'll get a three-month
emergency food kit plus a free water
filtration system so you can have clean
water to drink and cook with your my
Patriot Supply three month food kit
gives you a wide variety of delicious
meals and it provides over 2 000
calories a day which is highly important
for keeping up your strength and energy
order today and get your free gravity
powered water filtration system a 279
dollar value as a bonus gift the food
and your free water filter are all
shipped to your doorstep in discrete
boxes with free shipping included as
well go to prepare with reuben.com
prepare with reuben.com and now back to
me okay so what do we do about the lies
guys because they're coming in every
direction and as I keep saying the woke
are not going to stop lying the
mainstream media is not going to stop
lying the politicians across the board
are not going to are not going to stop
lying and we got to do something about
it now the first thing that I think we
can do uh is call him out for it and
before I do this segment because we're
going to start talking about Trump a
little bit and I know I know the haters
are ready and the people that are upset
with me already I just want to say you
are welcome to go back to my videos of
three months ago right and three months
ago what was I saying almost every day I
would like Trump and DeSantis to sit
down at Mar-A-Lago close doors we don't
even have to know about the meeting and
figure it out right figure it out now
that obviously did not happen there is a
case to be made for Trump trump is not
making that case Trump has decided to go
all in uh when it comes to lying about
DeSantis a couple weeks ago he was a
globalist and a rhino and he was funded
by George Soros and he sexually harassed
a girl in college he floated that for
about a week and his Sarah gets floated
that for about a week it did not work
now he's trying to make it seem like the
scientist wasn't good on covid which to
me when I saw this we'll get to the the
statement in a few minutes when I saw
this statement that Trump put out on
Friday it felt personal to me I have
moved my family here two companies here
about 20 people who I admire and love
who are all flourishing you all know all
the greatness about Florida but now it
says and he lives in Florida and two of
his kids moved to Florida during covid
and all his grandkids here his whole
family lives here he knows it's all not
true but he's throwing everything he's
got everything he's got and none of it's
true and we just if you love Trump if
you still think Trump is the best and he
got
cheated and he's the only one that can
fight the Deep State you have to think
about it for yourself do you want to be
all in on someone who will do anything
including lying including endless life
and I get politicians or Liars but like
absolute 180 reverse of Truth stuff
we're all gonna have to decide that so
let's let's get into it now here's Trump
a couple days ago talking to the nelk
boys about Florida and it's just it's
just nonsense it's just nonsense
why do you think he's what like besides
that because he's done a pretty good job
with Florida you agree why do you think
you're a better choice than DeSantis
well actually if you look at the numbers
he didn't do a great job if you take a
look at the numbers he's very high on
crime very high we're right at the top
uh almost at the top uh he I think he
gets good publicity although now people
are starting because I'm putting out the
covet numbers he didn't do well on covet
he had more deaths and almost every
country in Florida I hate to say it
because Florida's my state
but he had he did not have he did not do
well it's it's really it's very
interesting I don't want to knock
anybody but the thing he did well on his
public relations because uh the numbers
weren't what uh they pretended to be
with all of that being said when you
help somebody
I believe in loyalty you just don't do
what he did now he's out campaigning I
assume he's going to run but I think the
numbers are so bad now that a lot of
people are assuming that he won't run
and uh would you consider him like to be
your running mate I don't I I don't see
it I mean I don't see all right there's
just so much nonsense there look we've
played the videos before and I'm sure
we'll play them again I didn't feel like
doing it today there are a million
videos of trump all throughout covid
praising DeSantis right he's the best
he's keeping the state open I love the
guy I wish Michigan could be more like
Florida
etc etc uh the numbers also you know the
numbers of deaths first off Florida has
the second oldest population right
what's the joke about Florida right you
guys know this is this is where people
go to die this is this is Golden Girls
country uh now it happens to be uh
getting much younger and it's
flourishing in the business but you have
to blend controlling people's lives with
safety uh so it's just a absolute lie
about the numbers also we have good
weather here so you open up earlier
people get out and about uh does Trump
want to start talking about the fact
that he was the one that pushed for warp
speed and now his own base which is the
most anti-vax people out there uh all or
many of them got injected or were forced
to get injected or were friends or
spouses with someone who got forced to
be injected and mandates and all of the
stuff so he's just lying about Florida
and again two of his kids moved down
here with their children during covid
his whole family lives down here you can
find a million videos again I don't want
to be gratuitous about this which is why
I'm trying to do this in some kind of
measured way but you can find a
gajillion videos of Don Jr who I'm
friends with and I hope he's not pissed
at me you can find videos of him talking
about how great Florida is you can find
videos you could it was my my own show
where he opened for me at uh at the West
Palm Beach uh improv but we did an hour
on how freaking great Florida is so it's
just nonsense but okay let's just keep
going with this because a couple days
ago Donald Trump got several uh I think
it's about a dozen uh Florida Congress
people who are endorsing him together at
marlago so here's a picture from Corey
Mills
representative Corey Mills and he wrote
great dinner last night at Mar-A-Lago
with President Trump and members of the
Florida delegation honored to be part of
this great team and here are Florida
members who seemingly are supporting uh
Donald Trump for president that event
was on Thursday night on Friday morning
after 12 Florida Congress people
endorsed him and went to dinner with him
right it's all set it's a setup in that
we're gonna have dinner and post a
picture like this is we're going to do
some PR now the very next morning Trump
threw them all under the bus because he
put out a statement that was railing
against Florida and in essence about the
work that all of these people have done
so he just he talks about loyalty I know
Trump talks about loyalty uh even though
everyone that he's ever fired or worked
with is an idiot and a buffoon and a
and everything else he then put
out a statement in the morning basically
throwing all those people under the bus
I'll get to the statement in a moment
but now I want to read you just a little
piece from my friend in Colin honest and
several Reuben several times Reuben
report guest Carol Markowitz in the New
York Post here she's talking about Trump
and and what he's been doing on the
Florida Front a leftist think tank
called Florida one of the most expensive
states to live in a leftist organization
noted Florida is one of the worst places
to work she what she's referencing here
guys uh is this the Trump statement
because Trump really went off on Florida
and she's debunking some of the nonsense
yet over 700 000 people have moved to
Florida in the last few years and they
keep on coming someone let them know
leftists and Donald Trump think Florida
is super bad on Thursday a number of
Florida members of Congress who had
endorsed the president's re-election
campaign even after he recently said
that Democrats like Charlie Crist also
did a great job in the state stood
grinning for a picture at Mar-A-Lago the
very next day they were forced to answer
whether they too believe Florida and
this is Trump's words continues to
Tumble into complete and total
delinquency in destruction all of this
is a lie desantises winds in Florida are
celebrated because he has taken smart
conservative policies and implemented
them well to Wild Acclaim in what used
to be a purple state but is under his
leadership now reliably red it's what
winning looks like Donald Trump
supporters need to ask themselves how
much of that are they willing to
sacrifice to defend their guy and why
okay again guys you know what's funny
on on in the locals Community I put up
posts that are just for our for our
locals paying members and on Friday
morning before this Trump statement I
was taking a walk with Clyde and I put
up a little video asking everybody sort
of philosophically uh how I should be
doing this this Trump DeSantis thing
because first off again DeSantis has not
announced yet
um I voted for Trump as I said I like
him personally I'm not trying to make
everyone crazy about politics it's the
reverse of how I do this show right so
what do I do with this and at the end of
the day it's like look if DeSantis was
lying about everything I would be
calling him out about it DeSantis pushed
through this six-week abortion thing I
don't agree with it I was fine with the
15-week thing I have no problem saying
that but I don't think we can let these
lies go go uh go unanswered and it's not
just the lies it's that now he's going
after the most successful conservative
Place probably in the world the place
that is the most defensive of Freedom
end of the American dream The Citadel of
Freedom right that's what the scientist
calls it and that's what Trump is
willing to do on his personal quest for
power
which is odd because he used to really
like Florida and Ron DeSantis
the governor like Ron DeSantis of
Florida is doing a great job we're in a
play school in Florida and we have a
great Governor great governor knows
exactly what he's doing terrific job he
just announced that the schools will be
open in the fall governor of Florida Ron
DeSantis who's done a
spectacular job in Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis doing a fantastic job enjoys
very high popularity and that's for a
reason the reason is he's doing a good
job Governor's done a great job Florida
is down low now in the
he's done a lot of things right and
you're open
open close and you're it's just amazing
right A lot of people agree with what
he's done Ron DeSantis of Florida the
governor doing a fantastic job in
Florida you're Governor Ron DeSantis
who's turned out to be just incredible
in the coronavirus you see is going down
rapidly proportionately relatively when
you look at your nursing home situation
it's a tribute to your governor and
government the job they've done you've
done a really great job and you have a
very big nursing home population you've
done a fantastic job well I have a lot
of confidence in Ron DeSantis a lot of
faith in Ron DeSantis to make the right
decision he's been doing a great job in
working very hard he's a great Governor
he's done an incredible job and he's
doing a great job as Governor we have a
great job Ron DeSantis great governor of
Florida he's been a fantastic governor
for Florida they're very happy with him
Ron's doing a great job one of the
greatest governors in our country and I
know a lot of good ones and I can tell
you there's some really bad ones too but
this is a great one Governor Ron
DeSantis
Connor just said to me at the end maybe
he's talking about a different Rhonda
said it's like do you get it guys do you
get it
Trump knows these are all lies like you
really need to understand two weeks ago
Trump is calling him a globalist and a
rhino he's calling him disloyal just a
few days ago now he's calling him bad on
covid it's just an abject lie and you
have to decide all of us have to decide
again me as someone who voted for Trump
and if Trump is the nominee I likely end
up voting for him again but like we all
have to decide is this what we're going
to do and then and then we wonder why
we're in Endless destruction and we live
in a world where where truth doesn't
mean anything and we don't know the
difference between boys and girls and
everything else well truth it's vital to
the to The Human Experience and it's
connected to everything and if we just
let a certain set of people lie all the
time we will get screwed by those lies
too right if you it's like a tar pit the
dinosaurs and the Tar Pits it and one
dinosaur jumps in then another dinosaur
is trying to eat that dinosaur he jumps
in next thing you know he's sinking in
the Target pits too and we all end up as
fossils it does not end up well so yes
there is a million other there are a
million other videos of trump praising
DeSantis he knows he's not a globalist
he knows he didn't have an affair with a
16 year old he knows he's not disloyal
and who has Trump ever been loyal to and
he and he knows he wasn't bad on covet
as a matter of fact he knows this is the
best place in the country right now
because of the covid policies and all
the people that have uh fled here but
since Trump wants to play dirty how
about we just go to some of Trump's own
words because Trump was big on lockdowns
and not happy when Governors uh fought
against them and tried to open up
we did the right thing we closed the
country down could have kept it open and
I could have done what some countries
are doing I had to shut it down we did
the right thing I thought of keeping it
open and we did just the right thing we
closed it down and a group of very smart
people walk in and say sir we have to
close it
and we did the right thing they can't do
anything without the approval of the
president of the United States even the
Democrats aren't blaming me for that we
had to close it up some people wish we
never closed it down we did the right
thing we closed it it's a decision for
the president of the United States we
did the right thing we had to close it
up because nobody's ever heard of
closing down a country to let alone the
United States of America we had to turn
off the airlines we had to turn off
everything
and we did the right thing a lot of
people have thought about it write it
out don't do anything just write it out
and think of it as the flu
but it's not the thing
it's vicious we basically shut down our
country you know we did the right thing
we had to close it down the president of
the United States calls the shots and we
had to close it down we did the right
thing they're not working in offices
they're not in airplanes together and we
did close up we had to close it up and
we did the right thing we closed it down
we did the right thing we closed it up
we were told to got to shut it down stop
it tell everyone to stay home
because of this horrible virus and we
did that we had to artificially close
our country we've done this right and we
we really we really have done this right
that we did the right everything we did
was right okay so you watching this if
you still love Donald Trump and I get it
I get it he has Vengeance in mind he has
all the money in the world so maybe he
could correct his mistakes of last time
and everything else are you afraid to
challenge him on that like does it
bother you that I'm playing that video
right like you got to think about that
why does it he screwed up an awful lot
of and I grant a huge leash on this
what do I always say about covet I grant
everyone the one month leash for sure
two weeks to flatten the curve and then
everyone gets like a little more of a
curve but he was calling for shutdowns
and fighting with Governors and
everything way after that one month
period right so while he's ranting and
raving about DeSantis being the worst
who he used to say was the best uh he
might want to look in a mirror so how
about Donald Trump if you're going to
tell the truth if you're Mr truth teller
how about boy I did screw that up you
know maybe I shouldn't have listened to
those experts like fauci and Bert uh
Burks right maybe I shouldn't have
pushed through warp speed maybe I should
have stuck to my guns more maybe I
should have given more power to the
states again I'm only bringing any of
this up because he is relentlessly lying
and and I just won't stand for it I
can't explain why exactly I also think
there's a weird thing going on with uh
the people that are that are against
Trump that everyone's afraid of
something when it comes to Trump but
nobody knows what right like people are
I think they're afraid of the mob
because there is an angry Twitter mob
and everything but it's like if you're
the most hardcore Trump supporter most
likely you are on backs as I said
earlier you were certainly against
mandates you didn't want the country to
lock down you you're not happy about
warp speed you're not happy about fauci
and a whole bunch more do you think he
should be held to account on that is
that a little swampy that he was
listening to all of those people
Etc et cetera and yes guys it's not just
the month of covet here he is April 15
2020.
but there are many states out there that
are looking at this and they're
reviewing it and they're saying we
shouldn't be even included in this you
know there are some that want to open up
almost now now if we disagree with it
we're not going to let them open
we're not going to let them open if some
Governor said you know has a lot of
problems a lot of cases a lot of death
and they want to open early we're not
going to let it happen Okay I don't even
know that the president has the
authority or had the authority to not
let a state open a state can decide what
to do for itself and thank God for that
thank God for federalism and the fact
that Kirsty gnome in South Dakota and
Ron DeSantis here in Florida and a bunch
of other Republican Governors fought the
federal government fought Donald Trump
actually Brian Kemp fought Donald Trump
because Brian Kemp in Georgia was trying
to open up and Trump was not happy about
it because well he was listening to
fauci
I told the governor of Georgia Brian
Kemp that I disagree
strongly
with his decision to open certain
facilities which are in violation of the
phase one guidelines I would advise him
not to just turn the switch on and go
would I do that no I'd keep him a little
longer I want to protect people's lives
and I went to Deborah and Dr fauci and
other people and they weren't thrilled
about it I think it's too soon and I
don't want this thing to flare up
because you're deciding to do something
that is not in the guidelines there is a
danger of a rebound they can wait a
little bit longer just a little bit if
you ask me am I happy about it I'm not
happy about it safety has to predominate
and I'm not happy about Brian Kemp there
are some that want to open up almost now
if we disagree with it we're not going
to let them open but I didn't like to
see spas
at this early stage you nor did the
doctors going ahead and leap frogging
into phases where you should not be I
would advise him as a health official
and as a physician not to do that told
him I want to reiterate one point you
might be watching this going Dave this
is a little gratuitous it's easy to play
Monday Morning Quarterback and blah blah
blah blah blah
I think there's some truth to that but
again where is Trump saying man I
screwed up all of that stuff
right because everyone knows he did in
my opinion now we should have never done
anything about covid right I regret that
I ever put on a mask okay but two weeks
after or you know basically the two
weeks a lot to flatten the curve and
blah blah I was fighting the whole damn
thing
the point is you're allowed Trump if you
have if you have any humility or if you
really again you're supposed to be the
hardcore uh truth teller why not be like
I really did get bamboozled by these
guys I really screwed up blah blah blah
instead you're focused on the guy who
did it better than you because I really
think that they're seeing some crazy
poll numbers I really do I I don't know
the poll numbers it's hard to make sense
of what's going on here I've always said
that about polls in general I think it's
getting more complex because of the
internet and all of that but he's
freaking out over DeSantis and he damn
well should it's it's as simple as that
but you know he's not freaking out about
and he's had some nice things to say we
played a clip last week Gavin Newsom
well here he is praising Gavin news and
this is from before two weeks ago but
Trump kind of likes gav you know little
man crush
look at what's going on in California
where they're doing a fantastic job they
really are the governor's doing great
I'm proud of them I've gotten very
friendly with Gavin Newsom he's done a
very good job here I watched
what's been happening in California with
Governor Newsom and this morning with
Governor Cuomo and I applaud them
they're taking very strong bold steps
and I applaud them we agree on the
coronavirus and on that we've got along
very well and our relationship began
earlier than most and so from that
perspective all I can say is from my
perspective the relationship has been
strong it's been a really terrific job
in California well we've gotten along
very well Gavin Newsom we've got very
well with regard to covid-19 as we call
it in that respect he's been fantastic
and we've been fantastic and he said
very generous things yeah California by
the way also doing a very good job
Governor Newsom yeah I'm going to meet
with the governor right now Gavin Newsom
we've worked very well together
guys I literally and everyone in this
room literally fled California because
of its endless lockdowns and because of
the crime that was running rampant and
all of the other stuff that which was
connected to covid the riots and
everything else and we moved to the free
state of Florida but you may remember
Donald Trump sat down with Tucker
Carlson what was it about a week ago and
said that he couldn't really criticize
Gavin during covet because Gavin was
really nice to him so it made it hard to
hit him
so there you go there you go he's
literally praising probably the worst
guy on covid and now he's attacking the
guy who is the best on covid but how
about a little bit more just TV tiny
come with me on this train ride just a
little bit more uh here's a 2020
campaign ad for Donald Trump I think he
may regret airing this one
the president has listened to what I
have said and with the other people on
the task force have said the first and
only time that I went in and said we
should do mitigation strongly the
response was yes we'll do it when He
suggests why don't we do this and I say
no that's really not a good idea from a
scientific standpoint he has never
overruled me the travel was another
recommendation when we went in and said
we probably should be doing that and the
answer was yes when I've made
recommendations he's taken them and then
another time was we should do it with
Europe and the answer was yes he never
counted or overwritten me and the next
time we should do it with the UK and the
answer was yes I never in the multiple
times that I've done that where I said
for scientific reasons we really should
do this that he hasn't said let's do it
the first and only time that Dr Burks
and I went in and formally made a
recommendation to the president to
actually have a quote shut the president
listened to the recommendation and went
to the mitigation
[Music]
guys don't shoot the messenger right so
if you're pissed at me right now Dave
don't show those old things and nobody
knew
how about the guy who's shown no
Contrition about any of it who literally
was still pushing fauci on US during his
re-election don't shoot me right I
didn't make those videos Donald Trump
made those videos so what do we do about
this right if we're going to have a set
of people
AOC on the left who's going to lie about
everything Donald Trump who's making it
clear he will lie about everything he
will lie about the freest state in the
world and the guy who's leading the
stadium he'll trash the place that he
lives in that his kids moved to and his
grandchildren he has no there's no rules
around him that's the way he's going to
do this okay so it is what it is
actually and again I might end up
freaking voting for the guy
but what do we do well there's a way
that we don't have to uh join him on
this this ride to Hell there is a way
and the way is supporting people that
are doing a better job and I'm very
proud to say and happy to say that the
Republican side right now has a bunch of
great people involved you may not love
all of these people on all of their
positions but obviously DeSantis
obviously Nikki Haley obviously now
Larry Elder right like it's vivec these
are these are people who are who are
mature
adults who are worthy of being on a
stage together and they should have it
out but clearly the guy who's the gold
standard right now is the scientist it
just is and that's why orange man is
going crazy on him uh here is uh
Governor DeSantis uh calling out Trump
this is just in the last couple days for
being weak when it came to fauci
the courage to make difficult decisions
in the teeth of opposition and criticism
a leader must have the confidence to
stand all alone if need be and so for us
as I got into office kovid presented
that situation for us because we were in
a situation the third largest state in
the country one of the highest
percentage of elderly Economy based on
tourism which we needed travel to
continue so this situation was an
existential threat to our state but I
made the Judgment
leaders take the bull by the horns and
make the decisions for themselves they
don't subcontract out their leadership
to health bureaucrats like Dr fauci
okay clear honest good now you might
watch that and again I'm really trying
guys I hope you can see it you might
watch that and go maybe DeSantis would
have been bamboozled by those guys too
and that is absolutely true but he
learned in real time real fast and
that's worth acknowledging Trump seems
to not have learned because he refuses
to uh look back at any of his statements
and say I screwed that thing up right
DeSantis very quickly after doing
lockdowns on the rest of it came around
and started doing the right thing
DeSantis actually spent the last couple
days the weekend he was over in Utah and
obviously you know this Trump thing is
heating up so he uh mentioned something
well it's Loosely on Trump and the
culture War
Republicans need to shake the culture of
losing that is developed in recent years
the time for excuses is over we must get
it done if we as Republicans provide a
fresh vision for American Revival then
Republicans will win all across the
country
okay it's it's clear and it's clean if
we fight appropriately if we don't let
this culture War always encroach on us
but we use power
cleanly and clearly and effectively and
when it should be used we actually might
do something and you know what you can
also do when you lead clearly you start
surrounding yourself with people who are
good and you don't get the petty back
and forth and you don't get the leaks
and you don't get the constant just
chaos as opposed to how about just going
to work doing the people's business and
going home not giving them a show not
feeding the mainstream media with all of
the nonsense and everything else does
Santa talk about that too
we've been able to operate an
Administration that does not get
consumed and Petty controversy or drama
or Palace Intrigue we basically execute
the mission day after day after day and
we're able to keep an awful lot of
people on their toes in the process and
that's another thing about going in
particularly as an executive I look
around and sometimes Republicans will
get into office and they're almost like
potted plants they don't want to do
anything with the authority that they
have
okay guys I I think you get the point so
now look here we're getting to uh an
interesting place Ron DeSantis has still
not announced I think he is getting
close now to the window where he has to
because this thing is heating up in such
a crazy way Trump was so overboard in
that attack on Florida on Friday that he
might be sort of pushing the he's
pushing the envelope with what DeSantis
I think will put up with that would be
my guess on this thing but DeSantis he's
obviously bouncing around he was in
South Carolina he was in Utah uh he is
in Japan right now right so this picture
from yesterday uh Governor Ron DeSantis
and his wife Casey arrive for an
audience with Japan's prime minister
fumio kashida also there's a headline
from Politico uh Netanyahu says he will
meet with DeSantis now interestingly you
guys this is this is working out very
fortuitously uh for us because I get to
Israel I leave on Wednesday I get in
Thursday morning at 7am a.m I am going
to book it to Jerusalem where DeSantis
is talking hopefully I can get a couple
minutes with the governor we will see
and you know who knows what's going to
go on over there but interesting things
are happening by the way speaking of
interesting things I'm about to segue
all together for just a moment but we
were just told literally in the last
minute that Tucker Carlson is leaving
Fox News Now Dan bongino left Fox News
last week now Tucker apparently is
leaving do we have any more info I guess
we'll we'll get some more info uh but
it's a it's a I mean this is a game
there we go Tucker Carlson out at Fox
News it seems difficult to believe but
Tucker Carlson is no longer with Fox
News the announcement was confirmed by
the network this morning I mean this is
massive massive you gotta understand
guys Tucker Carlson
is the number one rated host in the
history of cable news the absolute
history of cable news I have no idea
where Tucker's going I have no idea but
I do know that when Tucker walked into
my house years ago for the first time he
said and I quote I'm gonna I'm gonna
drop an F-bomb for a second he walks
into my garage sees my whole home
operation and he goes holy
you're living the dream that's what
Tucker said so is he about to go
independent I have no idea but this is
this is absolutely huge obviously we'll
have more on that soon is this related
to the to the lawsuit and you know
everything else with dominion and all
that I I don't know but actually it's a
perfect moment because I was about to
segue to Tucker because Tucker I think
has been showing us in some ways how to
win by fighting the culture War
appropriately calling out the nonsense
not apologizing
etc etc uh and here's a video that we
just found of Tucker talking about how
you go ahead and Lead within 10
integrity and fight when you should
fight
ing was super obvious like those of us
who were in our mid 50s are caught in
the past in the way that we think about
this one side's like no no you know I've
got this idea
and we've got this idea and let's have a
debate about our ideas they don't want a
debate
those ideas won't produce outcomes that
any rational person would want under any
circumstances
those are manifestations of some larger
force acting upon us
it's just so obvious
it's completely obvious
and I think two things one
we should say that
and stop engaging in these totally
fraudulent debates
where we are using the terms that we
used in 1991 when I started at Heritage
as if maybe you know I could just win
the debate if I marshaled more facts
I've tried that doesn't work
and two maybe we should all take just
like 10 minutes a day to say a prayer
about it
I'm serious like why not
all right so there's a bit of a winning
model I think it's something that I've
been trying to model here to some degree
too right you can't just
say the right thing all the time and
hope that that will proliferate around
right if you're always losing the
culture of War right I think this is
something that conservatives and again
when I say conservatives I mean this
broad Coalition of people just decent
people who believe in reality I think
one of the things that we've done that
should be the tagline I should start a
new party decent people who believe in
reality the most controversial racist
party in the history of the world
you can't just do it that way you can't
because they will just keep coming you
will you will lay out facts and they
will ignore those facts they will live
in their reality they won't accept basic
biology all those things so what he's
saying is you have to have sort of a
holistic approach when it comes to going
back on offense yeah you have to have
facts and you have to have reality and I
think you know often at the end there
when he says talk about praying it's
like that there's a spiritual component
of this there is something that's within
you that will make you stand up straight
with your shoulders back that then will
allow you to approach properly if you're
all banged up spiritually or otherwise
you're not going to be able to get out
there and build anything you'll be able
to destroy a lot of things and paint
your hair blue and burn down a uh you
know a federal building in Portland but
you won't actually be able to create
anything so what we have to do is deploy
this model the model that says I've got
the truth on my side I've got facts on
my side but I know how to get it across
again what I try to do here with a
little bit of comedy and a little bit of
silliness is have everyone kind of
understand and these issues in a way
that give hopefully really hopefully I
give you something that you can do
something with right if I don't then I
would say find something else to watch
but I think that that's kind of what
we're doing here and I and I know it's
working for me personally so you deploy
the model you actually say I will fight
when it when I'm supposed to fight as
you know that is exactly what governor
DeSantis did here with Disney Disney
just announced a whole bunch of layoffs
this morning uh and this fight has just
begun because they're going to sue him
now he's going to go back and forth but
I guarantee you Disney will not win
what this proposed piece of legislation
will do if you remember when we first
went down this road last spring a lot of
folks in the media were saying that oh
my gosh Disney's actually going to pay
less taxes and Floridians are going to
pay more taxes they were saying that and
I'm like you've got to be kidding me
well this puts that to bed and so those
debts will be honored and those will be
paid now this is obviously now going to
be controlled by the state of Florida
which is no longer self-governing for
them so there's a new sheriff in town
and that's just the way it's going to be
okay one more time I don't want to beat
a dead horse you must understand guys
taking away special privileges because I
still keep seeing this stuff uh get
pushed in mainstream media even this
morning right before we started the show
I saw a clip on Fox news with Kat timpf
who I had on the show last week who I
like a lot and Steve Hilton who's a host
on Fox talking about how this was too
much you know government overreach this
isn't friendly business tactics to go
after Disney but it's it's just simply
wrong taking away special privileges so
everybody has the same even playing
field that's what capitalism is all
about that's what Fair governance is all
about right that's that's what we're now
doing here in Florida and that's what
Disney is upset by so oddly you have the
leftists who are on the same side of
some of the conservatives right we've
shown you the videos of Mike Pence
saying ooh DeSantis went too far by
taking away special rights Chris
Christie DeSantis went too far some
these other Fox hosts that's who I like
right like that's a friend of mine so I
think there's some confusion about what
good governance is but interestingly
interestingly guys if you lead properly
occasionally some of it the airlock of
the mainstream media which which is
going to lie about us relentlessly
eventually some of it actually gets
through it's wild when it does CBS
CBS which is mostly crap at least their
news Division I don't know what's going
on on the entertainment Division I don't
have cable anymore uh they aired a
segment about the parental rights
movement that is proliferating
throughout the country uh they talked to
my friends over at moms for Liberty
podcast and it wasn't terrible and I
thought okay that's sort of interesting
here's just a little bit
the book genderqueer was in our school
libraries had moms for Liberty not
brought that book to your attention it
might still be there launched in 2021
the group now claims 275 chapters in 45
states with 115
000 members and Counting never bet
against a mom I mean nobody's going to
defend anything like a mom is going to
defend their child
Tiffany Justice and Tina daskovich both
former Florida school board members
founded moms for Liberty we're joyful
boys joyful Warrior their aim to play
hardball with a smile we are organized
we are angry and we know our rights
enjoy the time you have left we want
people who are serving in elected office
that respect the role of the parent in a
child's life so in 2022 our chapters
endorse in over 500 School Board races
across the country and they won 275
seats what kinds of books do you want in
schools in libraries books that educate
children
that's a generalization that the books
that don't have pornography in them
let's start there let's just put the bar
really really low books that don't have
incest pedophilia you see what I'm
showing you guys here CBS which has been
unkind to say the least and NBC and ABC
and all of them which have been really
unkind to parental rights and education
the bills the politicians that are
pushing it Forward they lie about don't
say gay and what what's happening with
the books and all of those things even
now they're like oh I guess we can't
totally hide this so they did like us I
don't know basically a fairly decent
piece
for people on our side and that is good
but it's only good well no it's good for
many reasons but it's only possible
because more and more people are
stepping up and fighting for the right
thing I've met those ladies they're
they're fine ladies actually the moms of
Liberty I've done a couple things with
them and some Florida blueprint events
and hopefully I'll do some things in the
future and I've done their podcast and
and a bunch more but the point here guys
is that something positive comes when
you tell the truth it is true that
something negative comes when you lie
but it is also true that something
positive comes when you tell the truth
Jordan Peterson
if you tell the truth you have no idea
what's going to happen to you it's like
I'm going to say what I think and then
what I'm going to assume faith I'm going
to assume that whatever happens if I am
telling the truth is the best thing that
could happen because the truth brings
about what is best and even if it looks
hard for me because it might be you know
because people take the easy way out
often when they lie even if it looks bad
for me that doesn't mean it's bad it
just means I don't see the whole picture
but one of the remarkable things about
that and this really is worth knowing is
that if you do that you will have your
adventure right the that's the abrahamic
adventure the call from God that
justifies your life because of the
excitement of what you're doing and the
truth does that and then if it's the
truth man it's your adventure because
what bloody Adventure are you having if
you tell someone else's story it's not
yours and maybe if it's not yours it's
not good enough for you and then you
suffer and then you're bitter and then
you're cruel and then you're resentful
retired to a show together for the
people today did we tie it with a nice
little red bow do a little something for
people you guys got it
you guys got it man I have to say I'm a
little distracted by this Tucker thing I
mean this is a massive shock wave
throughout
the culture right the culture because
Tucker became bigger than just a guy who
is reporting the news or sharing his
opinion in the evening he became much
bigger so in a show where I was trying
to address just that uh he has now left
Fox News we will find out more about
that I will continue out there trying to
tell the truth with my Mafia shirt I
hope you guys will do the same we've got
a post game show for you guys in about a
minute at
reubenreport.locals.com if you want to
help keep us independent right I have a
feeling Tucker is going independent I
don't know anything on the inside I
swear but my guess is he's going to
follow the road that I've been blazing
for quite some time uh my full interview
with uh Oscar winner and acting Legend
Richard Dreyfus is up right now and it's
it's not about acting it's not about
Jaws or anything else it's about
politics and Civility and and a whole
bunch more really interesting guy that's
up across platforms uh we got a great
cold close from The Babylon B for you
and I'll see everybody on the other side
just
foreign
[Music]
mcgrendelson will you be an angel for a
helpless live every day innocent lives
are ratioed flamed and even neglected
for just eight dollars a month you can
sponsor a liberal providing them with a
blue check and more importantly with
hope that's about the cost of one white
chocolate low whip almond milk latte
light broth or one gallon of gas call
now your donation will provide identity
verification all the benefits of Twitter
blue and a newfound sense of self-worth
to a poor needy lib plus you'll receive
a photo and regular updates from your
sponsored lib everyone knows the only
people worth listening to are blue
checks don't let a lib become an
absolute waste of a human being browse
our database of needy lips today
please act now because due to inflation
eight dollars will soon be worth four
dollars and then you'll have to pay
sixteen dollars right now there's a lib
who's in need and you can help don't
wait every minute more Libs Fade Into
Obscurity and even though they are
definitively rich enough to pay it for
themselves their liberal world view
dictates that you should be the one to
shoulder the burden
it's the compassionate thing to do
I want it I want it
[Music]